dernier garçon il me dit maman il m'a
été assassinés alors je peux te dire je
maman je senti que le monde et la fin de
ce mois parce que c'est un garçon aux
proches je croyais qu'on leur sécurité
latifa benghiati raconte elle a perdu
son fils imad un jeune militaire de 30
ans victimes du fanatisme religieux
cette femme franco marocaine ne cesse
d'envoyer un message d'amour de paix et
de tolérance
le but sensibiliser le public aux
dangers de la radicalisation pas mal de
jeunes que j'ai croisé l'un en ce sens
cette fragilité de divorce abandonné des
parents etc je n'ose pas parler
facilement et voyez ça parle quand vous
bougez leur coeur et cette fragilité ça
peut tomber facilement dans les pièges
pour la tipa la famille et l'éducation
sont deux piliers essentiels ils ont le
pouvoir de combattre la violence et le
terrorisme
les collégiens ont posé beaucoup de
questions et se sont sentis concernés
[Musique]
c'est la fin de la conférence
les collégiens à courre effets relatifs
pas dans leur coin
j'ai trouvé que c'était très émouvant et
très courageux de sap courageux de sa
part et qu'elle nous a fait partager un
beau message ce que nous a appris ce cas
nous a dit faut toujours avoir la tête
haute
faut pas pourquoi faut pas baisser la
tête
la laïcité c'est un enjeu excessivement
important qu'on a parfois du mal à faire
passer aux élèves il faut bien et on
utilise tous les outils qui sont à
disposition et là c'en est un
fondamental
la ville d'orléans prend la
radicalisation très au sérieux elle a
mis en place un dispositif
d'accompagnement avec des éducateurs et
des psychologues dont on considère qu'à
chaque fois qu'un jeune commence à
changer de comportement rupture avec la
famille rupture avec ses propres amis
rupture avec les études immédiatement on
sait que ce sont des indicateurs ce sont
des signaux d'alarmé et que nous devons
nous réagi
et agir pour aider à ce qu'ils ne
basculent pas latifa compte bien
continuer son combat et tenter de
vaincre la haine avec pour seul var mme
m'écoute l entraide